We live in a dynamic world that’s always
moving.
Nothing would get done if everything stayed
still.
It’s this very movement that gives us life,
that allows the blood to flow through our
veins and gives action to our stories.
But what does this mean to us as engineers?
What’s really happening when things move?
Well, since pretty much everything has mass,
most of the movement in our world is associated
with mass transfer.
It’s critical to our work, our lives, and
something that we should learn more about.
[Theme Music]
We’ve talked a good deal about transfer
so far.
Whether it was momentum transfer,
as we saw with moving fluids,
or heat transfer, like stepping out in the sun
or touching a hot pan, we’ve seen how things
move and change.
But when people think of mass transfer, they often
think of something pretty simple – the movement of
an object, or fluid’s mass, from one place to another.
But that’s not really what it is.
That’s more like bulk fluid movement, which
we learned about in fluid mechanics.
No, what we mean by mass transfer is a bit
more complicated.
Mass transfer is the movement of
individual molecules and components
within a larger mixture or substance.
So it deals with what makes up something
like a stream of water rather than its bulk
movement as a whole.
Now, because mass transfer works on this often
microscopic scale, it has a lot to do with chemical
separation and can literally be crucial to life itself.
To see what I mean, think of drug delivery.
And no, I don’t mean like driving around
a delivery truck of pharmaceuticals.
I’m talking about medicine moving within
the body itself.
Medical treatment depends on medicine getting
to the right place in your body.
It often needs to go through your mouth, to
your stomach, and then into your bloodstream.
Or maybe it needs to be injected into a certain
location.
But a drug might be less effective if it’s
not taken correctly.
Sometimes it won't even work at all.
For instance, people with Type 1 and often
Type 2 diabetes have to take insulin by injection,
in places like their arms or their stomachs.
Just swallowing insulin, in pill or liquid form,
wouldn’t work, because it would break down in the
patient’s stomach acid before it could do its job.
But let’s assume a certain medicine is taken
correctly.
Then its individual molecules and medical
compounds have to move through the fluids
in your body to the right location.
There’s a lot more to consider than just
that, but at its core, drug delivery is all
about mass transfer.
It’s about how one type of chemical moves
through other chemicals to get where it needs
to go in a mixture.
So how does that mass get transferred?
Well, it needs a driving force.
We learned that for momentum transfer, the
driving force was a difference in velocity.
For heat transfer, it was a difference in
temperature.
For mass transfer, the driving force is a
little more complex.
Let’s think back to thermodynamics.
We said that everything was always trying
to reach thermal equilibrium, or a balance
of temperatures.
That’s why temperature differences drive
heat transfer.
For mass transfer, we’re still trying to
reach an equilibrium, but this time it’s
a chemical equilibrium.
Chemical equilibrium can be explained in terms like
chemical potential and fugacity, but those are pretty
abstract concepts and difficult to directly measure.
Which, we as engineers, need to do.
So for our purposes, a better way to explain
chemical equilibrium is to approximate it
in terms of concentration.
Simply put, concentration is how much there
is of something in a certain amount of space,
or volume.
Here, we’ll look at concentration related
to mass, so it will be mass per volume.
So for something to reach chemical equilibrium,
it’s going to need to have the same concentration
throughout.
That means that, when left alone, and not
acted upon by another force,
particles won’t move from one location to
another within a fluid or a substance if there isn’t
a concentration difference within it.
No concentration difference, no mass transfer.
If there is a difference, then the concentration will
move from the higher concentration to the lower one.
But concentration isn’t just something we need
to worry about for a substance or fluid on its own,
but also when it mixes with something else.
To keep things simple, let’s just talk about
fluids for now.
Let’s also assume that the fluids are fully
miscible, which means that they can be
completely mixed together.
So, when one fluid is put into the other one,
we can view the combined fluids as a single
mixture in terms of mass transfer.
That means that the fluids will mix together
until the solution has the same concentration
throughout it.
Well, how do they do that?
One major way is through diffusion.
Diffusion is when the molecules of two or
more things intermingle as they move from
higher concentrations to lower ones.
To see what I mean, let’s use an example
that you can do at home!
If you take a drop of red food coloring and
mix it in with a glass of water,
you’ll notice that the red color slowly
spreads throughout the glass until the
solution is the same color.
That’s diffusion!
And the more food coloring you add, the darker
and redder the solution will be.
No matter how much you add, it will eventually
diffuse into one uniform color, given enough time.
And how fast something diffuses can be very
important as well.
This especially comes into play when thinking
about safety.
For example, you’ll want to know how fast
certain acidic or corrosive chemicals can
move through your protective rubber gloves.
Or how fast chemicals can enter your body
when you’re exposed to them.
Or how quickly they can diffuse through
your skin or organs to reach vulnerable parts
of your body.
That’s why whenever you work with hazardous
chemicals, you protect yourself so that the rate
of diffusion is as low as it can be.
What if you’re trying to produce a chemical
for sale – or maybe just convert a toxic
chemical into something safer –
so you pass the raw material through a
catalytic converter.
Reactions will certainly occur on the surfaces
of all the catalytic particles inside,
but how fast the molecules diffuse to the catalyst
surfaces will affect how much product you get,
and how fast the reaction will even occur!
Now, if we really want to be able to understand
and quantify mass transfer, then we’re going to
need to learn about Fick’s Law.
Fick’s Law states that there’s a drift,
or movement, of particles from denser
regions to ones that are less dense,
or that they’re moving from a high
concentration to a lower one.
So, pretty much what we just learned.
Fick’s Law defines the rate of this drift
– the diffusion, or mass flux in our case,
as proportional to the product of the
thermophysical property – which is the diffusivity
constant or coefficient –
and the driving force – which
will be our concentration gradient.
The negative sign here shows us that the
diffusion will occur in the direction opposite
that of the increasing concentration,
or from a higher concentration to a lesser one.
Now, D will either be called the diffusion
constant or diffusion coefficient, depending
on who you ask.
But in all practicality, they mean the same
thing.
That’s a debate more of semantics than application.
And the concentration gradient you’ll see
here is the derivative of our concentration
in the x direction.
If you're not familiar with derivatives, they’re
basically rates of change.
What’s important to remember is that, while
we’ve been focusing on the mass transfer of
particles themselves moving,
this movement is going to be making the
overall mass of whatever the particles are in
move as well.
So this small movement can lead to bigger,
bulk movement.
The tiny particles won’t be able to get their overall
mass to move in certain obstructed directions, like
getting water to move through the glass that it’s in,
but they can cause bulk motion into more
open directions, like the air above the water.
In the end, when things are moving, there’s
a lot more going on than just mass transfer.
But it does give us the basis to understand
some of what’s going on.
Just because particles are small, don’t
count them out.
Get enough of them moving, and you can make
a big change.
Now that I’ve said that out loud, that actually
sounds pretty inspirational.
So in today’s lesson, we learned all about
mass transfer.
We found out that it doesn’t just apply to objects
and fluids as a whole, but also to the individual
molecules and components that make them up.
Then we saw that transfers of mass need their
own driving force, which we found to be concentration,
as things try to reach a state of chemical
equilibrium.
Diffusion was a way to get to this balanced
state, and we were able to use Fick’s Law
to help us model mass transfer.
I’ll see you next time, when we’ll talk
about separation and apply what we just learned
to mass transfer equipment.
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check out a
playlist of their latest amazing shows, like The Art
Assignment, The Origin of Everything, and Physics Girl.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and this
episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.